hey guys i'm abby sharp and welcome to
abby's kitchen and to another edition of
what i eat in a day youtuber review
today i'm going to be reviewing dr dre's
youtube channel so dr trey is a
dermatologist and her channel features
mainly skin care techniques and tips and
routines uh vlogs vegan recipes and some
lifestyle content as well as a few what
i eat in a day videos so for our new
format for what i eat today we're going
to look at a few of dr dre's wedding day
videos so that way i can give you a more
well-rounded commentary on any of the
themes i see any of the good or not so
good information on our channel and some
general patterns rather than cherry
picked meals now before we start a
general disclaimer that the information
in this video is for educational and
entertainment purposes only and you
should always seek out the help of a
registered dietitian for your unique
case i also want to note that today's
videos are particularly triggering for
any of my followers who are currently or
who have previously struggled with
disordered eating so feel free to skip
this one if it's too much for you okay
let's meet dr dre but i am not a
registered dietitian so do not take what
i eat in this video to be you know
what you should eat necessarily it just
happened to be what i ate today
but yeah coffee is imperative i
i love that dr dre is being upfront with
her viewers about not being a dietitian
and this video is really just about how
she eats and not necessarily about how
you should eat i don't want to take
credit for this but i do feel like since
i started this series more and more
youtubers are throwing this into their
wedding a day so i'm not sure if that's
to prevent themselves from being like
commented on but regardless i really do
appreciate when youtubers without
relevant credentials take the
responsibility and are transparent with
their viewers uh with a cup of coffee
and i love the four sigmatic coffee
grounds i've been making them lately in
this french press alternatively i also
do espresso typically on the stove with
my bioletti in which case i will add in
some chaga elixir i love the taste that
gives to things it just makes things
really earthy and enriches the flavor of
the coffee okay so totally on board with
starting the day with coffee not sure
that the four sigmatic is to my taste as
we've already established but if it's
working for dr dre it's working for me
as a vegan it is important that i take a
supplement every day to support my
vitamin b12 needs i get my supplements
from care of and this video is in
partnership with care of
so if you're not familiar with care of
it is a great service for getting your
vitamins they're incredibly reputable
and they make it so easy you just take a
quick five minute quiz and carob will
then suggest which vitamins you need
based on your dietary requirements or
lifestyle
the vitamins come in these cute little
dispenser packs and each are
individually packaged with your name and
a cute little
message or in this case a little puzzle
and uh yeah as a vegan you know it you
spend a lot of time reading ingredient
lists to make sure there's no added
gelatin and things and it can be really
tricky but with care of they make it
pretty simple
and a no-brainer so if you're at all
interested click the link in the
description box okay so side note not to
be like too nitpicky but dr dre probably
should have disclosed her sponsorship
with care of supplements at the
beginning of this video as for ftc
guidelines but anyways i digress i am
really happy she's taking a b12
supplements regardless i think it's just
the really responsible thing as vegan um
influencers to be discussing your
supplement regime with your followers so
i definitely applaud that she's making
note let's see what's for breakfast so
yeah that was my breakfast this
particular morning again pretty early in
the morning but i enjoy eating that uh
and it keeps me full for several hours
so i am a big fan of soaps and i see
that she put some plant-based protein
powder in there some oats zucchini
almond milk frozen bananas and then she
topped it off with some sunflower seeds
cacao nibs and some fruit i actually
have some really great zotz recipes on
my channel so you can check it out right
here and i'll leave the link in the
description as well but there's a lot
going on here in dr dre's zote so i
think our breakfast has a nice balance
of carbohydrates protein has a little
bit of fat i mean it looks really super
tasty and i think that's a pretty
satisfying portion for sure it's like an
entire family size bowl
so i would definitely think that she's
going to be satisfied for a little while
let's take a look at breakfast number
two from one of her other videos i start
every morning with a
big old thing of water like most
youtubers but i don't do the lemon water
i do natural calm it's just a magnesium
drink
but it flavors the water nicely and
honestly it helped me cut back on
drinking diet soda and i no longer drink
diet soda or diet coke and i attribute
it to the natural palm it just has a
nice kind of fizzy taste i love the
cherry flavor okay so this is taking an
interesting turn
um
natural calm is a magnesium supplement
and while magnesium plays an important
role in our bone health and metabolism
not everyone needs this type of
supplement i personally use it at night
time to promote relaxation and better
sleep and there's evidence for that um
and also because my doctor recommended
me to take it that is a legitimate use
but in this video dr dre suggests she
drinks it every day because the
magnesium drink flavors the water nicely
and helps her cut back on diet pop this
is why sometimes flavored vitamins or
gummy vitamins can be a bit of an issue
because we tend to over consume things
that taste really good and excess
vitamins and electrolytes are not benign
in the case of this natural calm
i would be worried that she's depending
on it not just for water flavor but for
its laxative properties this is actually
one of my big complaints about the
product taking it myself you know i love
that it helps with my insomnia it can
literally give you the
magnesium
is a natural laxative and just adding it
to your water all day will definitely
clear you out i'm not here to make any
accusations but i just want to flag that
this supplement may have some serious
side effects when consumed in excess and
adding a few scoops and spoonfuls every
single day i don't know if she's doing
this multiple times a day it's a lot
there are a ton of other non-diarrhea
promoting ways to stay hydrated and keep
your water intake exciting you know by
adding fruits and herbs to your water or
just drinking plain carbonated water
with like a little spritz of lemon okay
enough about that let's see what's next
i love the four sigmatic instant coffees
know this video is not sponsored by four
sigmatic so a lot of people will go on
and speak to
how they uh try these for certain
potential perceived health benefits
me however i only consume this stuff for
the taste i love it i mean people add
stuff to coffee
why not add mushrooms and it really
jives things up and it doesn't taste
like mushrooms whatsoever okay so i
actually really liked dr dre's comment
about the four sigmatic
instant coffee i've heard a lot of
youtubers praise the wonders of four
sigmatic coffee and tea products
specifically talking about their health
benefits of reishi mushrooms and
adaptogens and all that and while it may
be true there really isn't enough
research to confirm these claims so i
really like that dr dre consumes the
coffee just for the taste and not for
the supposed health benefits though i
must say
i did try one of these four sigmatic
products and it was just
not for me but
different strokes for different folks
apparently
often we'll take my b12 supplement at
this point or else a little bit later in
the day
someone who follows a vegan diet like
myself needs to supplement their diet
with b12 so make sure i get that in
always discuss with your health care
provider what supplements are necessary
for you
don't just follow advice on youtube it
can be incredibly misleading and
especially if you have some underlying
medical things going on or you take
medications amazing i think it's really
responsible for dr dre to disclose to
her viewers that she takes the b12
supplement again
to supplement her vegan lifestyle but on
top of that dr dre even encourages her
viewers to speak to their healthcare
provider about supplements so even
though she is promoting certain
supplements in some of her videos she's
still emphasizing the importance of
finding the right supplement that works
for you and i really love that okay
let's see her breakfast in this video
i've really been into these little mason
jar salads
i don't know maybe it was some pinterest
rabbit hole that got me on this but i've
got some spinach here that i'm packing
into the jar
hashtag team plantain i just enjoy them
over potatoes i find that they are more
satisfying um and then i'm going to top
in some hemp hearts a really good source
of protein and lots of important
vitamins and minerals i also douse in a
few tablespoons of nutritional yeast and
then a serving and a half each of a
mixture of black beans and navy beans
that i made up in my pressure cooker
some cherry tomatoes are going on top
and then i drizzle some apple cider
vinegar which
trickles down through the jar and kind
of mixes with the nutritional yeast and
the hemp hearts and makes like a
dressing basically i top it with pumpkin
seeds and ancho chili for spice okay
like savory breakfast i think that's
pretty cool so dr dre said she's having
the same thing for breakfast and lunch
which is fine when you're in a pinch i
mean it's not like a large salad there
doesn't seem to be
a lot going on other than a lot of
spinach so i see a small portion of
beans in there so at least we have some
protein and fiber there um but it's
pretty low in fat and carbs yes we see a
little bit of pumpkin seeds and hemp
hearts uh for the fat and a tiny bit of
plantain for the carbs but still i mean
i would need a lot more of that to have
a full healthy balanced hearty
satisfying meal i don't see an issue in
adding like a little bit of avocado oil
or olive oil however i'm getting the
sense that she is part of the no oil
army
okay well on that note let's give my
overall view of dr dre's breakfast well
day one was probably a little more
substantial than day two but i get that
she was just maybe in a pinch and had
meal prep the night before and that's
cool i think both meals could probably
do with a little bit more fat and i
don't like the no oil trend that i'm
sensing with dr dre but in general
neither are really bad options let's
take a look at lunch go ahead and put
down a base of spinach
so put down a good serving here in the
base and this is some brown rice i
prepared in advance in my kosari slow
cooker i just put half a cup of brown
rice that's a serving and once the
edamame comes out of the microwave you
can just put it in as is but this
particular day i wanted to take the time
to pop it out of the shells which was
yeah i i like to eat soy based foods
edamame tofu tempeh
textured vegetable protein
a good source of not only protein but
also some other vitamins and minerals so
i make sure and get that in and yeah
this is what a full serving actually
looks like it's quite a bit more than
what you might expect
um and then i like to top everything
with nutritional yeast have you guys met
a vegan that does not like nutritional
yeast i i have yet to find one it's so
tasty and it you know add some b12 and
vitamins to things
and then i also dust on some asho chili
ancho chili
and some white wine vinegar and
then i just kind of let that incubate
overnight okay so dr dre's salad looks
pretty balanced there's fiber from the
brown rice in the spinach there's
protein from the edamame and a little in
the nutritional yeast and hemp seeds not
a ton uh but still a lot of definitely
very nutritious ingredients here
oh but it's like the no oil thing
i'm so over this
okay let's take a look at meal number
two and see if there's any updates one
of these for
brunch if you will or breakfast i know
that sounds odd and then the other one i
end up eating for a lunch
oh yeah
we've already seen it because she's
having the same thing for breakfast and
for lunch that day and that's cool i
mean the two meals taken together
however do seem really low in calories
especially considering they're mainly
just spinach and there's not a whole lot
of protein or fat so i'm getting a
little bit concerned
uh and hungry i mean
i'm definitely hungry so what are my
thoughts on dr dre's lunches overall
well spinach is obviously a favorite
staple of dr dre's which is great
because it's a rich source of nutrients
but these lunches do seem a little low
in calories protein and fat we maybe
could boost up the rice or add some
fruit or sweet potatoes for some more
starch add a bigger portion of beans for
a little bit more protein and for the
love of all that is holy don't be scared
of oils i feel like the idea for balance
is really there but i just feel like
some of the proportions and portions
seem off let's see how things look at
dinner it's night time and it's time for
me to make dinner i chop a lot of my
veggies in advance
so i have them prepped but tonight i'm
making a mustard ginger uh veggie soup
with
green split peas i'm just chopping up
the ginger
in this i'm going to be using about a
third of a
head of savoy cabbage that i have
chopped here i'm going to use some
parsnips i've got about half of a white
onion
turnip
these purple turnips and a chayote
squash and i've got a bunch of spices
here of course the split peas
and these are some whole mustard seeds
dill
turmeric fenugreek anise bay leaves and
black pepper yeah i recently started
cooking with mustard seeds i just put a
teaspoon of mustard seeds in or so it's
a definitely a good idea to track your
food in the beginning of transitioning
to a vegan diet because it's easy to
under eat uh you're
you're able to eat what seems like a lot
of food uh just because the fiber
content makes you a lot fuller on fewer
calories so it can be helpful to track
in the beginning but i've kind of gotten
used to
what i need to get my caloric needs so
yeah that's it after about an hour of
slow cooking two walk cups of water in
there and the other thing i love to have
is my airfryer radishes i have recipes
on on this i mean it's not rocket
science i just pop a whole bag of
radishes into the air fryer if you hate
radishes you should try this you might
like them better it takes the bitter
radish taste out of it makes it more
like a potato
so my soup's pretty hot but i want to
eat it so i'm going to do the add a
frozen frozen produce thing that i did
this morning to the pot i just add some
kirkland stir fry vegetables get a
little extra broccoli in there and
whatnot
there is my dinner it is delicious you
guys okay so
lots and lots of yummy veggies going in
plus split peas for protein and fiber
but as i watched her preparation i
noticed yet again
i didn't see any addition of any oils or
fats and then she goes on to dump an
entire bag of frozen vegetables so while
i totally love a good split pea soup and
i love that she snuck in lots of extra
veggies it's still not a really balanced
meal on top of that she starts her meal
with another huge bowl of spinach with
some sesame seeds and once again just
vinegar and that whole bag of radishes
that were cooked without any oil in the
air fryer
the volume that this meal has without
any real substance is kind of
mind-blowing i mean something does not
feel right to me now i don't want to
make any assumptions here but at this
point i feel like i need to make a point
the large volumes of vegetables the
vinegar without any oils on anything all
of that reminds me of some of my old
disordered eating days it's actually a
bit triggering to me as these are the
kind of tips that you'll read on proana
sites i'm going to talk more about this
but i'm really just hoping that i'm not
going to see a pattern with dinner
number two let's take a look here i am
i've got some washed and dry kale but
i'm just de-stemming here i'm just
chopping up a white onion i just put
some no salt added vegetable broth some
garlic minced and that onion i'm gonna
let it steam cook down
i then add some fresh cracked pepper
i do salt the food but i use sea
vegetables just gives things a little
bit of an added mineral kick
some iodine as well and then i put in
all of that kale and as you can see it
cooks down quite a bit some more hemp
seeds i told you guys i put those on
everything
and
so it just i don't know kind of adds a
little nice crunch then i forgot i
wanted to throw in this portobello
mushroom this is not like a recipe i'm
making this up as we go along together
based on things that are in my fridge
including this red cabbage that i needed
to get rid of so that's going in
and while that steams down i'm going to
make my salad i love salads and i have a
salad uh every dinner i'm putting
shredded zucchini or yellow squash into
my salad it adds a nice texture
difference this is my little salad
dressing concoction i just put on that
frontier co-op pizza seasoning onto the
salad and then i throw in a little apple
cider vinegar into the mix and just
drizzle it on over and
then i will probably add some hemp seeds
to this as well
for a little extra crunch but i go ahead
and pop that in the fridge with a lid on
it and just kind of let the seasoning
and vinegar coat everything before i eat
it
at this point my kale and red cabbage
have steamed down along with the
portobello mushroom i'm adding a little
bit more of the no salt added vegetable
broth to the pan and then a whole bag of
the rice cauliflower that i get from
costco in the freezer section and when
you put it in and cook it down it cooks
really fast like a minute and it's
almost like a fried rice kind of then i
add on again some fresh parsley and
black pepper i also dump on a lot of
nutritional yeast because i love that
stuff but it always obscures the
aesthetics of things so i'm just showing
you what it looks like here okay well
the volume is
mind blowing i mean she's eating an
entire head of kale something that would
maybe take me like a week to get through
plus cabbage plus portobello mushrooms
plus rice cauliflower and onion then an
entire family size salad with a whole
head of lettuce more spinach radishes
mushrooms and zucchini which i can only
imagine is a lot of fiber to try to
digest in one sitting especially at
dinner time before bed i can see why she
shops all the time at costco because the
grocery bill must be insane also she's
using no oil at all in fact she cooks
her vegetables in broth which again
takes me back to the fat phobic days of
my orthorexic self so
yeah like i am genuinely feeling
triggered watching this right now
but i want to give my final thoughts on
dr dre's dinners i'm a dietitian so
seeing someone eat their greens with
such enthusiasm is so exciting to me
having said that there is such thing as
too much of a good thing and the fiber
in this meal is out of control also
having a history of disordered eating
and having made it to the other side i
know why she has to eat two huge bowls
of food to fill her up it's because her
meals offer very little substance and
too few calories throughout the day
vegetables are super low in calories but
high in fiber and volume meaning you can
eat a lot of them for a small amount of
calories and feel really full
at least temporarily and while satiety
is very important so is actual nutrition
and this meal is really low in protein
and fat i mean if she were to add in
some tofu and oils even avocado to the
salad
i can assure you that she wouldn't need
this huge portion to feel satisfied now
listen i don't want to tell anyone that
any portion is necessarily too big or
too small that is for your stomach to
decide but when a meal or a day is so
unbalanced that you need to have an
entire fridge worth of food to feel full
i can absolutely point out how we can
change that okay let's move on to
something where hopefully there's no
spinach
dessert i have a bad feeling i'm going
to be disappointed all right for dessert
i'm making a rice pudding i love doing
this i just take some of the rice in a
mugs pretty easy you can also use this
as a breakfast by the way just top it
with a little bit of cinnamon there
and i'm gonna be putting in two scoops
of the protein powder again
but because the protein powder is sweet
i didn't add any sweetener but if you're
not using that you could do maple syrup
or stevia or whatever you want um and
yeah just give it a swizzle and nuke it
in the microwave and then i put it into
a pretty bowl for you guys and topped it
with some cacao nibs
this is a nice sweet delicious treat and
the carbohydrate at the end of the
evening kind of helps with sleeping okay
that's like an interesting
take on rice pudding i mean it's like a
fitness magazine version of rice pudding
it's a little diety for my taste but i
mean it's fine um it probably tastes
good and i like that it has a nice
balance of protein from the protein
powder fiber and carbs from the brown
rice and of course i mean yes it's
virtually free of fat and sugar
obviously but that seems to be the theme
here let's see day two in my soy milk
yogurt with a little bit of the coconut
sweet leaf stevia drops and i top it
with
some honeydew melon uh top it with some
cacao nibs and i also okay this is a
this is an amazing little find you can
thank me later these pomegranate arils i
don't know i'm saying that right or not
this i don't know if you can see it's a
little chocolate pig to make these i use
the swerve chocolate cake mix
this is a no sugar baking mix that is
made with coconut flour and almond flour
the ingredients in the mix are
completely vegan
but it calls for eggs in order to make
the recipe however you can just
substitute in a flax seed egg or a chia
seed egg i use flax seeds it also calls
for oil but i find that it comes out way
too greasy if you use oil because of the
coconut and almond flours i used pureed
squash and it worked really well
okay so she's got some homemade soy
yogurt with some fruit and cacao nibs
and a brownie that she made with some
sugar-free brownie mix i mean this looks
like a nice way to finish off the day
but i have to flag that even though the
brownie mix calls for oil she says that
they come out too greasy so she used
puree squash
so no sugar no oil i mean
girl
do not call that a brownie now what are
my thoughts on dr dre's desserts well i
like that she's incorporating dessert
into her routine in general but again
this just solidifies my suspicions that
there are some real deep-seated food
phobias going on
not only is she making brownies from a
sugar-free brownie mix but then she's
refusing to follow the already reduced
calorie instructions and use vegetables
instead of oil in the mix i also am
surprised that she has any space in her
belly for dessert after two family-sized
serving bowls of food that she had for
dinner but i'm going to comment more on
that later i quickly now want to talk
about her snack so let's take a look at
video one usually i'm able to eat
everything in that
meal prep container in one sitting but
i like to have snacks throughout the day
as well i make sure and get in a quarter
of a cup of almonds and i use that old
spice jar it holds exactly a quarter of
a cup and then i also take two
tablespoons of hemp seeds with me i'll
sprinkle that on top of the meal prep
container okay like almonds make a great
snack because they have the combination
of fiber and protein and healthy fats i
have noticed however that dr dre seems
really obsessed over exact servings i
mean when adding her almonds to that
glass jar it's almost like she's
counting each and every almond before
throwing it into the jar
i don't want to speculate again but i'm
almost getting the sense that her meals
seem a little obsessive and may even be
triggering for some of my viewers who
are watching i mean i know that it's
definitely triggering for me but let's
take a look at snack 2. i've really been
into these jungle peanuts and they taste
to me like those candies boston baked
beans which were like candied peanuts
these kind of tastes like that i also
throw in some more pumpkin seeds and
some raw almonds i also take some
mandarin oranges and hashtag team prune
all the vegans that i watch on youtube
are all about dates i am in the minority
i love prunes
okay so like that looks like another
great snack she's got lots of fiber and
natural sugars from the prunes and
mandarins and i'm also liking having the
mix of nuts in there
having said that i want to flag again
that prunes have a real laxative effect
and this plus the magnesium plus the
excessive fiber-rich greens have got me
a little bit concerned too much fiber or
an overuse of laxatives can actually
cause constipation
not to mention a huge dependency as we
impair the natural function of our
digestive tract too much fiber can also
cause nutritional deficiencies as it can
actually interfere with your body's
ability to absorb essential nutrients
overall i think that her snacks look
really great i love snacking on nuts so
not a whole lot to critique on that
front but let's take a look at dr dre's
overall daily nutrition
first of all
is her diet balanced well based on a
rough calculation dr dre is getting
around 2000 calories per day which is
well within the recommended range for an
active woman like herself her diet is a
little bit high in carbohydrates which
is okay and while her protein intake is
considered moderate her fat intake is a
little bit low
most problematically is that she's
getting almost 100 grams of fiber each
day which is almost four times the
recommended amount now evidence suggests
that anything over 70 grams is very
likely to cause bloating gas and
constipation though even a lot of people
have these unwanted symptoms after they
reach 40 grams of fiber in extreme
situations excess fiber can also cause
intestinal blockages and deficiencies in
minerals like calcium magnesium zinc and
iron on paper yes she looks like she's
getting enough of the major nutrients
that she needs and enough calories but
it's more the strict food rules or how
she's getting them that's throwing me
off so that brings me to the important
question
are there problematic claims or
assumptions with this diet and channel
now i did a bit of research and noticed
that dr dre absolutely avoids oils and
butters and just sticks to nuts and
seeds i don't want to speculate because
i don't know why dr dre avoids oils and
butters but i will speak to why some
people follow the oil-free diet
oftentimes people avoid oils because
they claim that highly processing of
oils removes the nutrient content of
food and it's better to go directly to
the source so like eating seeds instead
of having sunflower oil or olives
instead of having olive oil however
there are options of oils that are less
processed like cold pressed oils also
there are situations where certain oils
can actually preserve the nutrient
content of a food so for example olives
need to be cured or pickled to be edible
and that curing process actually removes
a lot of the polyphenols whereas these
polyphenols can be preserved
in extra virgin olive oil now in dr
dre's case when you're only restricting
your fats to nuts and seeds you can miss
out on the benefits of other healthy
fats and it also means having to eat a
lot more nuts and seeds to meet your fat
needs which of course also boosts up
your fiber as well with a vegan diet
already cutting out a variety of foods i
wonder that following an oil-free diet
adds additional unnecessary restriction
which is both a physical issue and more
problematically a psychological one the
other thing i want to bring up is the
portions i noticed that she's eating
fairly light meals in the early part of
the day only to have a super high volume
dinner plus dessert if she were to
spread those calories out throughout the
day by having a more satisfying
breakfast and lunch
with a little bit more substance in
there she maybe wouldn't arrive at
dinner needing to eat such volume this
would probably really help with
digestion especially right before bed
while dr dre didn't mention any
problematic claims directly to her
viewers i found that some of her actions
did speak louder than words and are
reminiscent of some disorderly practices
before i go any further i want to
preface what i'm going to say next by
saying that i have a lot of empathy for
dr dre
i have seen some really mean accusatory
videos about her being anorexic and if
she is in fact struggling i think we
need to handle this gently and
compassionately
i do not want to embarrass her and i
don't want her to feel bad about her
choices i don't think she's purposefully
trying to promote dangerous behaviors
she's really just using her best coping
mechanisms and for that i have a lot of
empathy having said that for her
vulnerable followers who are watching me
right now i want to flag some
problematic behaviors that taken
together i don't necessarily want people
to emulate the avoiding oils and using
only sugar-free dessert mixes drinking
laxative water all day meticulously
measuring and counting food and servings
and consuming massive volumes of meal
towards the end of the day
i want to make it clear that i'm
absolutely not diagnosing any of this as
an eating disorder but i can say that as
someone who lived in this world
all of these are things that i was
taught to do to keep me trapped in my
eating disorder i'm sad to say that
there's a lot of pro-ana sites out there
that will tell you about using magnesium
supplements as a laxative avoiding sugar
and fat at all cost weighing your food
or eating huge portions of greens to
fill up without consuming too many
calories i also remember pretty much
starving myself all day only to eat
uncontrollably at night it's almost like
when your energy levels dip so too does
your willpower to restrict i honestly
had a really hard time watching this
video because it reminded me so much of
my former unwell self and while i don't
believe it's dr dre's intention to make
people sick or to trigger these feelings
i'm just putting it out there that i
felt incredibly triggered on a better
note is there anything of value that we
can take away from this channel well i
do like that dr dre seems like a
responsible youtuber likely because she
is also a healthcare provider herself in
both of the videos that i reviewed dr
dre mentions that she takes a b12
supplement to complement her vegan diet
and also discloses to her viewers that
she's not a dietitian so you know it's
not like she's saying that this is the
way that you should eat in another
moment where she's promoting a
supplement for a brand that is
sponsoring the video she still
encourages her viewers to talk to their
doctor about choosing the right
supplement for them all of this is great
advice so i really appreciate that she's
taken that angle bottom line
i would say that dr dre's meals are
fairly balanced according to a nutrition
calculation but the level of rules and
restriction is sadly obvious i hope that
she's able to see this critique as
coming from a place of empathy and care
and not something that she needs to
defend my goal with these reviews is to
point out responsible content and
problematic content to help you make the
best decisions about what is useful and
healthy for you on the internet so
please please please keep the comments
below respectful and kind with that in
mind well that is all for today folks if
you liked this video please be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below with the youtuber that you want me
to review subscribe to the channel and i
will see you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
you